with the
with music it's easy to
it's easier to lock in you know what i
mean because
you can
enjoy your own music on your time or
like you could you know what i mean you
could you could work on it without the
people being there you can get back
and so then when you got the people
there
you get in-ear monitors you know what
i'm saying and you got so you got the
[ __ ] right into your [ __ ] brain
and so when the [ __ ] is going right into
your you can you in there
and it don't really matter what's going
on in the room you can lock into the to
the song in a way
that you can't with like comedy you can
catch that vibe sometimes if you riff in
or something they really roll in you can
have those moments but it's it's tough
to like
constantly have it and it's work to
constantly have it versus like if you
like your songs and you believe in your
[ __ ] and the shit's right going into
your brain
it's you could be in a whole
in a whole nother world when you when
you there was was comedy like exhausting
you like were you over comedy i could
feel that i was that in it you know what
i'm saying like i was up there you know
and i didn't i wasn't
i wasn't like
it wasn't it wasn't joyful and so
you can't i can't be in that that zone
because it's not about the
like yeah i couldn't like keep doing it
especially with what people
pay for my tickets i can't just be out
there like
you know
half-assing and that's where i felt like
i was doing i was just going out there
so yeah it was just you know
shifting in and
and
yeah the music's a rebirth yeah yeah
that's cool and was it like uh
overwhelming almost like like the the
sort of popularity of it and with movies
and [ __ ] like was it like is it a relief
to be sort of starting
back at like
zero with music you know versus like
you know the comedy had got you like
such a
i don't know so much notoriety and the
movies and everything
it's a
yeah it's like a
you can just
this is his differently man just to to
be able to
just capture different [ __ ]
in that way
work on it and
different topics all type i talk about
you know playing basketball
playing basketball i talk about ball and
talk about veneers talk about you know
i'm able to reflect on
things in my
comedy career addictions
gambling in a way
where
some of the songs are funny but i don't
always have to play for that that laugh
or i could you know
you could use detail
and and other things being specific
about without
you could have you know
i just uh
yeah i just didn't you know enjoy it in
that in that way
and
yeah
who don't i might get back into it at
another time like fully so it's not a
but it's just
it is this thing because like you know
you know
and especially in this phase
that's
you know where
what people have seen
and know you know that okay we know that
can make money but a dog hey come do a
comedy like so it's like
it's heaven it's having is having a
conversation over there no i want to do
meals to get that [ __ ] like hey can you
come to him like i don't know you want
me to do some songs
yeah yeah i'll give you some strong
banters
i ain't trying to just come talk that
joke can you come to that
banter with music behind you i don't
really want to come through and tell it
uh but it's it's you know one of the
bits in the
the
video i watched last night was you're
talking about
going to
a riffraff concert yeah and how he
had his dj playing his songs in which he
was rapping
but he was just sitting there listening
to his own music yeah in front of a huge
audience yeah and he said
man that sounds like an easy night twerk
i'm gonna try it right now and you had
the dj play your own stand up and you
just stood there listening to your own
stand up and said uh-huh yeah oh yeah
the pickle juice like that yeah
yeah exactly and uh it occurs to me that
you know the way that
yeah i do i do the comedy and i do the
stunts and i've mixed them together into
this multimedia show i gotta believe
that it's that you don't have to be
forced to be oh am i here to do comedy
or am i here to do music like why not
marry your worlds together and just have
it be like just a night of entertainment
absolutely uh absolutely i think it's
and it's you know it's an internal thing
more so than anything versus you know
any real
forces
it's more of a
uh
shifting identity you know what i'm
saying i went right oh cause i've been
doing
i started doing stand-up when i was 19
you know i was and i'm i'm 39 so it's
just
that was the so did you start to resent
the pressure of like come be the funny
guy
not the pres it's just i think you not
the pressure of it just burn out it's
just like when you go up on stage now
for music are you nervous and excited
and like [ __ ] excited yeah also too
right now you know what it is i didn't
want to end up
doing
i it was like i love the the ideas that
i have from from parenthood i feel like
if i do instead of now
i would be getting into
dad mode too
of it i mean and that's that's also a
choice or decision too but that's where
a lot of the the new stuff will be
coming from i think that that's great
too
i've got a bit about getting a vasectomy
and when i do it i find myself thinking
man getting a vasectomy i
i'm a uh
sort of um
limit if i had kids i'd have all this
great material from having kids and i
got a vasectomy that just kind of
you know but you got material from that
too that's true you know yeah yeah and
it means just me overthinking all the
time but
yeah i'd be interested in in uh in your
dad mode comedy yeah it's like that
it's a it's a
it's a it's
it's dope seeing uh seeing the growth
yeah seeing her you know
she just turned one yeah but then again
dude there's like
there's the
there's some comedians that have
like old material about their kids and
now their kids are like 18 and and kind
of like wait a second
you know like big j had uh
like a bit about his his daughter
cutting
holes out of her underwear he's like why
is there holes in your underwear she was
embarrassed of her skid marks and
actually took scissors and cut right
which was a super funny bit yeah but i
think his daughter's like 18 years old
now right
yeah you got to like grow with the kid
the material has to grow with the kid
yeah yeah that's yeah where's like you
don't want to you know right
yeah it's like i got this one-year-old
joke but now i got a four-year-old yeah
yeah oh and then yeah you could all go
particularly scar them with brother
yeah
i'm talking about the kid being
horrified about the existing material
about them yeah yeah that's a
that things would stand up where they
know i became more
conscientious of it
earlier on
because it was jokes i've done about
family just thinking like and fun right
and you find out folks mad you find out
these things you like oh man so
it does kind of
on a on a personal level make you like
okay is this bit
worth
like that is it is it worth that just uh
to entertain in that in that way you
know what i mean like oh foot is this
person's uh
you know versus you know
maybe in 2011 2012
uh
didn't think of that too much like
whatever happens [ __ ] that's the
set this is life
whatever anybody can get it god damn it
right now it's like well you know as you
can you can write from wherever you
could come up with so you you know it's
more
uh
consideration
and uh right and
i remember you know a lot and you know
in music you could use
metaphor
a little bit more and yeah and that
could be subtlety and and multiple
meetings on things you could you could
hide stuff a little bit where
uh and you could protect people i think
that clip was awesome but not as awesome
as my new book a hard kick in the nuts
what i've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions which is out
september 27th and if you pre-order it
right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not gonna waste your time because
i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude